-That's a good entrance
right there.
-You've never run
the New York City Marathon?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, there is a theme here.
-It surprises you?
Is that -- yeah.
Have you ever?
-I've run it three times.
Thanks for asking.
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
You did run it three times?
-No, I have to say,
it is the best way
to see New York City.
Even if you, like,
run it really slowly,
it doesn't matter.
It is amazing
because every neighborhood
is different.
All the crowds come out,
they -- they get you home.
It's amazing.
It really is.
-There's other ways
to see the city.
-You're like,
"I'm still not doing it."
[ Laughter ]
-I'll watch on TV, yeah.
-Tour bus.
-I've been out.
I've rooted people on.
I probably rooted you on, yeah.
-Yes, I'm sure you have.
-It is kind of amazing.
You know what's fun is
when we do the show on,
I guess this Monday's show,
a lot of audience will show up
with the medals.
-Of course.
-And it's pretty cool.
-But they don't take them off
for like three weeks.
They got the medals on.
-No.
That's when you unfollow
people on Instagram, too.
You go, "I get it, you ran it.
I get it."
-No, dude, 26.2,
like, you want some cred.
You're like, "I ran it."
-Yeah, no, I could never run
even one mile.
Are you kidding me?
I'm not in that good of shape.
But I will tell you --
By the way, it relates to you.
I'm a big fan of yours.
I've known you for a while.
I have all of your cookbooks,
or a lot of them.
-You don't have them all yet.
-How many do you have?
-I'm working on my 17th.
-No, I don't have 17.
Is that right?
-How many do you think you have?
-Ballpark, I probably
have 6 or 7.
-All right. So I'm gonna
get you the other 11.
We're going to fill you in.
-I would love that.
-Yes, absolutely.
-But my dad got me a present
for Christmas, pretty recently,
I want to say, of yours,
"Bobby Flay Fit."
-Oh.
-Which is good.
-He must have got that
on a discount table
because that's like
six years old now.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe it was six years ago.
-"80% off! Here you go."
-No, but he got
this book for me.
But I also -- Kind of like
a -- like a backhanded gift.
It's like, "Hey, here's --
It's called 'Get Fit.'"
-Oh, "Bobby Flay Fit," yeah.
-Yeah.
My dad's like, "Hey, you're
looking a little doughy."
[ Laughter ]
But anyways, so he got me this.
But it's a great cookbook.
Great photos, by the way.
I do love your cookbook.
I love your stories.
And I made a vegetarian chili
out of this book
that is unbelievable.
And I go, "Well, I don't know
if it's gonna be good
without meat in it or whatever."
-Well, you're not a vegetarian,
are you?
-No, I did it for fun.
-Oh, good,
'cause I'm cooking pork later.
-Yeah.
-Just so you know.
-Yeah. No, I love it. Yeah.
-Yeah, I have to tell
a quick story, 'cause I don't
even know if you remember this,
but this is a -- this is
a Jimmy Fallon good-guy story.
-Oh, man.
-So -- you're like, "Uh-oh."
No, no, no, really.
So, Giada De Laurentiis,
who you've had
on the show before...
-Yeah.
-...good friend of mine.
She and I were gonna do
a daytime talk show.
And you know how, like,
you know, whenever --
whenever a new show
sort of, you know,
starts to get a little bubble,
you have to do, like, pilots
and you have to -- you know,
see how it goes, so to speak.
-Yes.
-And we use Rachael Ray's
audience one day as a surprise.
They were all just like
you guys are here.
And Giada and I came in,
and we took over the stage,
and we did our kind of bit
back and forth, you know?
And you agreed --
You don't even remember this.
You agreed to be our, like,
guest that we interviewed.
It was never going
to air anywhere.
And you just did, like --
you were just like,
"You know what?
I'm gonna do it for you.
You've been on my show.
I'm gonna pay you back."
And, like, you were amazing
as our -- as our guest.
The crowd went crazy.
I just want to let you know
the show never went anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
What happened was,
they thought that Giada and I
had great chemistry.
It was -- you know,
we're really killing it.
They did say that the guest
segment was not compelling.
[ Laughter ]
-That's ridiculous.
That is ridiculous.
That is not true at all.
-It's not true.
It's not true.
But I just want to --
But, you know,
that was a bunch of years.
And, you know, just thank you
for just being, like, you know,
just part of it, you know?
You just -- it's so awesome.
-You're a good man.
It's tough to book these things,
and you never know
what show is going to work
and not going to work.
-Of course not.
-But I'm a big fan
of you and Giada,
so, yeah, if you guys
are doing anything,
I'll show up to the party.
-Okay. You heard that, right?
Okay. Just want to make sure.
-Well, let's talk about
Brasserie B.
-Oh, yes, Brasserie B.
So Brasserie B
is my new restaurant
that I'm opening in Las Vegas.
I'm going to bring
a lot of different
of my own flavors to it.
I'm known for,
like, big flavors,
lots of chili peppers, you know.
-But you went to culinary --
-Yeah, I went to
the French Culinary Institute
in 1984.
-Is that right?
-Yes, it is.
-And I think I have
a photo here.
Did you cook for Julia Child?
-Yes, I cooked for Julia Child's
80th birthday.
Amazing.
-Look at this.
-I mean, I have to -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're right there.
-Yeah. There I am.
I'm one of these people here.
-That's pretty cool.
-Well, Julia Child,
I have to say,
I was lucky enough
to spend a little time
with her
when she was alive,
and she was
so incredibly gracious
to everybody
in the restaurants.
The one thing about Julia
was she knew
in the best way
how important she was,
meaning she would
come into a restaurant,
and before she sat down,
she would go into the kitchen
and shake everybody's hand
from the chef to the dishwasher.
-Really?
-Yes, absolutely.
And she was amazing.
And Julia liked to have
a good time.
I was lucky enough also to have
some lunches with her,
and she would sit down, and she
would call the server over,
and she'd say, "I'm going to
have an upside-down martini,
and keep bringing them
until I tell you to stop."
[ Laughter ]
-What is an upside-down martini?
-That's what I said.
I was like,
"What's an upside-down martini?"
She said, "It's mostly vermouth
with a little bit of gin."
It's the opposite. Yeah.
-Wow!
-She went for it. Julia.
-Lots of butter and lots of
upside-down martinis.
She lived for a very long time.
-Yeah, she's a legend. Come on.
-Absolutely.
-So you're opening up --
This is exciting.
So you get this brasserie,
and you're saying
your french fries...
-Oh, yeah. Well, here's --
My thing is,
I want to thank
the French right now
for giving us the best dish
of all time, French fries.
Everybody wants french fries,
no matter what.
-Yeah.
Talk to me about this
because I was asking you
about this backstage,
and you actually said that
you built a whole separate room
just for your fries...
-In the kitchen --
-...and that gets me excited.
Here's the thing a lot of people
don't understand.
In the kitchen --
Well, first of all,
in my kitchen
that I'm building now,
there's going to be
a room dedicated
just to making french fries.
-Yes.
-And most people
don't understand this.
It really takes two days
to make real french fries.
-What goes into making --
Because I think you go --
-You want the process?
-Yeah.
-Oh, you want the full process.
-I want to know.
-Okay.
-We all want to know.
Here's the way it works.
So you take, like,
a russet or an Idaho potato,
you peel it.
You cut it into
what looks like French fries.
You throw it into cold water,
you let it soak overnight.
You change the water a couple of
times, you get the starch out.
-Well, already that's the step
I didn't know anything about.
-Well, it takes a long --
Yeah.
So you get the starch out.
Then you pat them dry,
and then you blanch them
at lower -- at a lower heat,
like maybe 300 degrees,
in some cooking oil.
And you cook them
just until they're soft,
but they're not brown
because it's not hot enough.
So you're basically -- you're
tiring out the french fry.
You're getting it
nice and soft, right?
[ Laughter ]
Definitely edit that.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So then --
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
Where's the edit button?
-No, no, no, you can't
control what we air.
All right.
So you make it real --
you tire it and make it real
soft, right?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So you soften your potatoes.
-Okay.
Then you give it a couple --
give it a couple minutes,
and then you hope
for the best.
[ Laughter ]
Hope for the best.
And you give it a couple --
Let it rest for a half-hour
or something, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You're a better man than me.
-Then you try it again,
and then you try it again.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
You take a blue pill,
and then you go,
"Yeah, here we go.
Let's try this again.
Let's see what's happening."
And then you make it.
[ Laughter ]
-Then you turn up
the heat to 375.
-Oh, yeah, get it hot.
-And then you brown them.
-Yeah.
-And they're crispy,
and they're soft and delicious.
-Yeah.
-And then that's it.
-Yeah. So --
-French fries.
-That's french fries.
That's french fries.
-French fries.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh la la.
That was the sexiest...
That's the sexiest description
of french fries
that's ever been done.
Can we talk about
"Beat Bobby Flay"?
-Yes, we can.
-"Holiday Throwdown."
I don't know --
I've never been on
"Beat Bobby Flay."
You know why I wouldn't go on?
Because I don't want
to ever beat you.
I want to be friends with you.
-I really want you
to come on the show.
-No, you don't.
-Yes, I do, Jimmy.
-No, I only go on --
If you have a talk show,
I'm on it.
I don't want to --
-You limit your scope?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I think --
I want to see you win.
-Eh.
-I like it when you don't win.
But, you know, why --
-I created the show to get beat,
so I'm okay with it.
-I once watched a marathon
of you for...
-Eating your vegetarian chili.
-...30 hours of, like,
"Beat Bobby Flay."
It was on Food Network.
-Really?
-It was --
It was a three-day event,
and I watched every one.
-So you do do marathons?
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Come on! That's a great joke!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This guy's just unbelievable.
Come on! That's a fantastic --
That's a great joke.
-What do you call that, recall?
-That's a -- no, callback.
-Callback, callback.
-Yeah, that's great.
But anyways,
this "Holiday Throwdown,"
you're taking on other
Food Network stars.
-Well, yes.
And the great thing
about the the holiday
version of "Beat Bobby Flay" is,
it's all
the Food Network stars
that people know
who watch the network.
And they all think that
we kind of hang out together
and live together anyway,
which of course we do.
-Yeah, live in one building
like The Monkees.
-Exactly.
Bunk beds.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And -- But it is really,
really fun.
It's a great environment,
great atmosphere.
It's rated so well the first
couple of years we do it,
so people just
keep watching it.
Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a sneak peek at
"Beat Bobby Flay:
Holiday Throwdown."
Take a look at this.
-Bobby.
-What?
-What's your take
on the turkey tetrazzini?
-Well, this is like
an old family recipe of mine.
So I'm gonna use
turkey sausage
that I'm spicing up
with some Calabrian chili.
Egg noodles.
I'm going to make
a fontina béchamel
to kind of layer
it all together.
-Wait. So you're not
actually cooking a turkey?
You're using turkey sausage?
-Yeah. Well, there's turkey
and turkey sausage, Katie.
[ Laughter ]
-You're burning each other.
Why not?
Why not? Have fun.
-It's like, "Who's buried
in Grant's tomb?"
-Exactly. "Beat Bobby Flay:
Holiday Throwdown"
premieres Tuesday
on Food Network.
We're cooking a dish
from Bobby's new restaurant
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.
Brasserie B.